this issue came up earlier in the week
with the idea charges could move to
London that's BS that's bogus Dean
Spanos the owner the charges used much
more colorful language and profane
language than that but you know Chris it
got Peter King and I to talking a little
bit about this yesterday I want to get
your perspective as a guy who played the
idea of moving to London living in
London playing in London the road trip
becomes three weeks at a time because
it's not just gonna be you leave on
Saturday you come back Sunday night it's
gonna be you go to the United States
from multiple games your family's
uprooted there's exchange rate issues
there's tax issues everything is
different culturally what a shock and
you're in your early 20s I
I don't think players gonna want to play
in London on a full-time basis if they
move a team there I don't think so
either and hey I mean I would love to
live in London I mean we know it's one
of the great cities of the world but as
far as pulling off the logistics of that
that still does seem extremely difficult
to me you're right the exchange rate
there is an issue there and then the
other thing you know you kind of hit it
there at the end you know I just don't
know how comfortable players are gonna
feel you know if they grew up in West
Texas or or you know Oklahoma or
something like that and they're that far
away from you know hey mom and dad we
got a game this week you want to fly 12
hours to come see us or do that type of
stuff that's just gonna be hard to pull
off and you know that's one of the great
joys players have a playing in the NFL
is the fact that hey my family can come
and watch me and do those things and
it's just easy for them that that that
complicates things in a lot of ways you
know let alone yeah are you gonna live
there the whole offseason do I need to
get another house in the offseason here
in the States how does that play off
because I don't think a lot of guys are
gonna want to stay in London you know
all year long through and through you
know four consecutive years in a row you
know people are raised here born here
they're gonna want to be back here at
some point so there's a lot of issues
there and I just I don't see it
happening as much as I like the London
Games and think the London fans are
ready for an NFL team I think that
ultimately what the London fans will get
is eight games a year that are a variety
pack like a little cereal boxes where
it's going to be different teams it's
not going to be one home team I don't
think it works logistically and think
about the the ultimate leverage you
would have over a player on the teams in
the United States he just threatened to
trade into London right I remember Adam
GaSe used to threaten to trade players
to Cleveland that was one of the things
Jarvis Landry said earlier this year
threatened to trade a guy to London talk
about uprooting your life my god and I
could see veteran free agent contracts
with a no-trade to London clause in them
not just a blanket no trade clause just
you can't trade me to London the mere
fact that that would even be a
consideration the light shows how it's
just not it's and and again nothing
against London we can't wait to visit
but for football players yeah that's the
last thing they're gonna want to do and
Peter King made a point yesterday as we
were trying to figure out this whole
Chargers report at some point if you're
gonna have one team it does make sense
to have two you have a natural
Geographic rival they've got Wembley
Stadium and the Tottenham Stadium where
two teams could play and but again then
you have two franchises with 53 guys
each in London and all the coaches and
all the support staff it just I just
don't think it works the NFL seems
hell-bent on doing it although I think
part of it is Chris they like to create
the impression they're hell-bent on
doing it because that keeps the London
fans engaged if they think there's a way
that the dominoes fall that a team gets
placed in London yeah I think you're
probably right there at the end and I
don't know if we need to keep like
dangling out in front of them I think
they're they're cool I mean I don't know
is London I would like to know maybe
this is something we should put out to
all the people who watch our show when
you say hello to all the people in the
UK and all that you know do they really
want a team or are they content with
just like you said eight ten games a
year and that's cool enough I mean it
just it's still a soccer is king there
we know that let me tell you there's two
things first there are plenty of fans of
NFL franchises that would prefer to have
a variety pack of games in lieu of the
crap they have to see every true and
they go to the city
Bengals fans and and the other thing is
this Sam farmer the LA Times pointed
this out he was at the Rams Bengals game
in London a few weeks ago and when you
look at the newspapers in London and you
flipped through the sports pages there's
no mention of the NFL there's still no
traction it's a niche proposition right
and there are some very ardent and
intense NFL fans and we appreciate those
folks in the UK and in Ireland but at
the same time it has yet to catch on the
way they wanted to and maybe it will
take putting a team there to get the
people more serious about it to make it
something that is covered more than just
some oddity you don't kind of like here
when you've got Manchester United and
one of the other Premier League team
Liverpool playing in Charlotte okay
Liverpool yeah they're playing in
Charlotte do we really care about that
it really doesn't resonate the way that
that people would like it to from London
who are tied into the Premier League so
that all the stadium it doesn't resonate
well you're right and a lot of times in
those games they don't even play their
best players cuz it's like it's like a
you know hello
wave to the you know the American fans
type at or at least the London and I
went to one of those I saw I saw Leo
Messi sit on his ass for two hours yeah
right yeah so I mean at least when we've
returned the favor to them we're putting
our best players in the field and doing
all that but the soccer is a long season
that's another discussion all together
but yeah I just don't know if it's
feasible Mike I don't see how you could
do it not fair competitively to to ask a
team to go like have a West Coast trip
and be away from home for 3-4 weeks in a
row or whatever it may be that that is
going to be too tough and not fair for
them you know as far as just wins and
losses as the season goes along yeah I
mean think of how strange that will be
the talk has always been there would be
an East Coast base of operations for the
London team where they would they would
act that and that would be a separate
headquarters where you'd be for three
weeks at a time your road trips would be
three four games and then you go back to
London for three or four games it just
doesn't make sense there's so many
issues so many logistical problems I
don't like it I understand why they talk
about it but
don't think it ever London Redcoats
verse the New England Patriots would be
a great matchup though I would really
like that that would be cool yeah that
would be that would be a revenge game
the rest right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports